stylistically Richard and dingler and
are much further apart and so what
influence he has is very interesting I
think we've already seen it in their
taste in music that they seem to
exploring new kinds of music you know
whatever cheers you up and gets you
ready to play it's fine but uh it is
fascinating I I think and in the last
couple of days ding has shown a new side
he is much more open and let's say
chatty he's giving away a lot of private
details and that's a slight personality
change even ending so that's been quite
interesting I don't know if Richard is
responsible for that but I don't think
they have worked together before
and you know Richard
is a very strong player but also clearly
stylistically far away from ding